today is election day in Georgia the
race is extremely tight one recent poll
had Republican Herschel Walker just
narrowly beating Democrat Rafael Warnock
other polls have Warnock up slightly
over Walker an estimated 1.85 million
ballots have already been cast because
Democrats changed all the voting rules
in recent years to give themselves the
advantage of early voting experts
predict over 1.9 million absentee
ballots will eventually be counted by
the time that final tally comes in and
because we have become a laughing stock
Banana Republic the media are already
reporting that we likely won't know the
winner tonight
let's talk about election day do you
expect we're going to have an answer on
Tuesday night or is this going to take
extra time to determine the winner what
are you preparing for
listen we're preparing for you know it
being a very tightness
um I anticipate we may not know on
Tuesday night it just it really depends
because it's up to the voters and
they're showing up in drugs
so happy election day we will keep you
updated whenever the Democrats find the
votes that they need to win I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Hunter who
says Michael said it's Iran but then
Michael said so anyway Iran I know this
is a problem because it is pronounced
Iran that is how Americans
ought to pronounce the name of the
country but I've I've just heard it so
much I've been inundated with the Iran
pronunciation from the liberal media and
Barack Obama and all the like it's the
same with Pakistan you know the the libs
pronounce it Pakistan and then they
somehow convince you that that's how
you're supposed to pronounce it they get
in your mind they control your words
they control your mind this it would be
the topic of my book speechless which is
a number one National bestseller makes a
great Christmas present a wonderful
thing to put in the stocking in your
home or in someone else's home and when
you want to protect those homes you've
obviously got to check out ring with
Christmas right around the corner many
of us will be traveling to see our
families and loved ones very soon you
may find yourself away from home more
often than not that is why I've decided
to team up with a ring with ring
security products you can rest easy
knowing that your home and family are
safe when you are not there the ring
doorbell notifies you when guests or
packages arrive Rings indoor cameras let
you keep an eye on kids and pets while
you're away ring alarm will alert you of
any motion detection while the house is
empty plus if you add smart lighting
around your home you can turn lights on
or off while you're away Rings home
security products don't just help keep
your home and family safe they make
perfect gifts for everyone on your list
head on over right now to ring.com
collections slash offers to find out how
you can live less stressed this season
with a ring product that is right for
you that is ring.com
collections slash offers tight race in
Georgia we'll find out who won whenever
they fix the pipes
they might have some pipes bursting
because even though they thought Walker
was going to get completely killed with
that October surprise about his
complicated and
unsavory love life in the past uh that
didn't quite happen it remains neck and
neck so the the liberal media are
predicting that they're just going to
keep counting for days and days and days
when you look at the presidential race
for 2024 you were seeing much more
interesting Dynamics going on right now
Donald Trump has fallen to the number
three most likely guy to win the
presidency in 2024 according to the
betting markets so this is not according
to public opinion polls this is not
according to the expert pundits this is
according to people who put their money
where everyone's mouth is and who are
staking real cash on who is going to win
so according to the betting markets
right now
uh
Trump is in third place he's got a 20
chance of returning to the White House
with four to one odds
uh Joe Biden has a 22.2 percent chance
of being reelected in two years on seven
to two odds
Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis they the Vegas
Betty markets are giving him 30.8
percent 72 odds
to win the White House so right now Ron
DeSantis is leading the pack and and
people have to take this seriously I
Know That No One Believes any polls
especially two years out from a
presidential election
but we're just seeing all the signs move
into santus's Direction so yes two years
is a long time the race hasn't even
really begun in the sense that Rhonda
Santos hasn't announced that he's
running for president there will be some
brutal primary process but if you're
just looking at the trend lines right
now Ron DeSantis is trending up
in pretty much every category he's got
the support of pundits and he's getting
more support from the pundits he's got
support in Iowa and New Hampshire and
Florida those early primary States and
he's getting more support in those early
primary States and now he's you look at
the the GOP big donors who are having
meetings with the candidates the reports
are showing that Rhonda Santos is doing
great with those GOP donors and then now
you've got the Vegas betting market so
this is a big problem for Donald Trump I
think part of the reason why Trump
announced that he was running so early
was to clear out the field and the the
common sense consensus view was that if
Trump announces he's running no one else
runs
right now Ron DeSantis would be crazy
not to run for president he's got the
wind at his back and
politics is about timing I know a lot of
people say well Rhonda Sanders can sit
this one out let Donald Trump have a
second term and then he can run in 2028
but that's not how politics works first
of all Ron DeSantis is not going to be
politically relevant in 2028 because
he's going to have to leave the
Florida's governor Governor's Mansion in
2026 that's going to be the end of his
second term and so then he'll be in
political no man's land for two years
before the 28th presidential race that's
not going to work also he's having this
moment now it's because of a lot of
factors it's because of covid it's
because of the great job that he's done
as governor in Florida it's because of
of what the other Governors and senators
are are or are not doing in the GOP is
allowed Ron DeSantis to really rise to
the top of the pack Ron DeSantis was an
unremarkable backbencher Congressman
okay the guy's been in Congress or the
guy's been in politics rather for a long
time and this is true of everybody in
politics you're just kind of there
until maybe you get your moment and when
you get your moment you've got to strike
think about Tucker Carlson Tucker
Carlson has been in political media
forever Tucker Carlson's been a
political media since the 90s okay I I
don't remember watching TV news when
Tucker Carlson did not have some kind of
presence but he wasn't considered the
big Power Player until just a few years
ago and now all of a sudden this is his
moment in political media same thing for
Republican politics and right now if I'm
Ron DeSantis I am thinking that all the
stars are aligning now as you know I
don't I don't really get too involved I
know that every pundit in the country
seems to have picked a candidate already
I have not done that
I love Donald Trump he's my favorite
President of my lifetime I think the guy
is just fabulous I really admire what
Ron DeSantis has done down in Florida I
think that there are plenty of other
candidates who could make good GOP 2024
uh candidates as well whoever it is
though we got to win the presidency
because even though the president
doesn't have anywhere near the power
that he used to and even though the
administrative State runs a lot of the
government and even though uh the
president especially you see this in the
Biden era is kind of just a ceremonial
role sometimes where even a man who
doesn't have two brain cells left to rub
together is able to just be sort of
guided around by his handlers and the
government continues to function but one
of the big areas where the president
matters is judicial appointments and we
are seeing a major major uh court case
right now before the Supreme Court that
could determine the future of marriage
and religious liberty in the United
States the case is called 303 creative
versus elenis this is a case about a
woman named Lori Smith who is a
Christian website designer and so Lori
Smith decides that she's going to get
involved in making websites for wedding
announcements you know where this is
going she is based in Colorado you know
where this is going it's the same state
that persecutes uh Jack Phillips who's
the owner of masterpiece cake shop
because he doesn't want to participate
in so-called gay weddings well Laurie
Smith decides okay I'm going to make
wedding announcement websites but I'm a
Christian and so I am not going to
participate in a so-called gay marriage
which violates my religious beliefs
the libs sue the LGBT Lobby Sues and now
this case makes it all the way up to the
Supreme Court there was a very telling
exchange between uh justice Neil Gorsuch
and lawyer for Colorado the solicitor
general there take a listen
I'm looking for the distinction between
the two cases one you say is okay the
other one not okay because the company
unlike our first example of the
speechwriter yeah the company here says
in no uncertain terms will they ever
sell a company as a a product or a
service to a same-sex couple no what
they say is we will not sell to anyone
anyone
a message that I disagree with as a
matter of religious Faith just as a
speechwriter says for the press release
right or the freelancer says I will not
sell to anyone
speech that offends my religious beliefs
but here they are defining their service
by excluding someone based on their
that's their religious belief
in Colorado changed their religious
belief right no but but well can you
protect religious beliefs son of the
statue right that is one of the
protected characteristics in theory
and in practice if it wasn't in practice
we had heard about it over over the past
several years and and my friend has
pointed to no example where this has
been applied to me the most telling part
of that exchange is when Justice courses
says look it's This Woman's religious
belief you can't change people's
religious beliefs right and Eric Olson
the lawyer for Colorado says no well
well actually that is kind of what we're
trying to do and and you see the framing
of the argument
the Colorado lawyer defending this
ridiculous LGBT law against Christians
against Jews against Muslims against
any reasonable understanding of marriage
he says This Woman's he's got kind of an
interesting voice this woman is she's
denying service to People based on their
sexual
desires she's excluding a group of
people and saying they can't buy her
product and and Neil Gorsuch says no
she's not
she's not telling any group of people
that they can't buy her product she's
just not offering a product that
violates her religious beliefs
it's not Jack Phillips the masterpiece
cake shop owner didn't say that gay
people can't buy my cakes he said I am
not going to create cakes that violate
my religious beliefs and to create a
cake for a so-called gay wedding
violates my religious belief so it's it
is it reminds me of the debate over gay
marriage which is you had the libs
saying that we want gay people to have
the same rights to marriage as everybody
else and the conservatives and the
reasonable people said everybody has the
right to marriage everybody has the
right to marriage
but marriage is the union of a man and a
woman for the good of the spouses and
the sake of the generation education of
children
everyone has the right to that
you don't have the right to radically
redefine that against what everyone ever
practically has always believed and then
the the
oral arguments got even worse from there
it almost kept me up at night it would
have kept me up at night if I weren't so
comfortable in my bowling brand sheets
right now go to bowlingbranch.com use
promo code Michael Christmas time gosh
isn't it everybody's favorite time of
the year if you want to enjoy that time
to the fullest you need to get the best
sleep you can every single night that is
easier than it sounds actually because
you just need the softest most luxurious
organic cotton sheets from Bowling
Branch I love bowling Branch they are
just
simply magnificent sheets bowling Branch
acted to me kind of like a drug dealer
actually because they gave me the sample
when they first came on the show years
ago they gave me the sample I said okay
then I got a taste for it when I start
buying more for me I start buying more
from my friends and my family I just 100
stand by bowling Branch 100 organic
cotton uh absolutely wonderful signature
hem sheets they're made with threads so
luxurious that three U.S presidents have
slept in them but who cares about the
presidents your favorite beloved
podcaster has slept in them too and
they're just so wonderful give the gift
of a better night's sleep this Christmas
season with bowling Branch for a limited
time get 20 off your first set of sheets
plus free shipping when you use promo
code Michael boltonbranch.com that is
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d-branch.com promo code
Michael
this very very important case up at the
Supreme Court 303 creative versus
Elena's uh is is hinging on this issue
of whether or not you can force people
to violate their religious beliefs and
participate in
something that they find immoral and
unconscionable and so Justice Gorsuch
brings up the case of Jack Phillips and
masterpiece cake shop and having to bake
the cake and participate in the gay
wedding and he says wait a second didn't
you send that guy to a re-education camp
here's what the Colorado solicitor
general says
Mr Phillips did go through a
re-education training program pursuant
to Colorado law did he not Mr Olson
he went through a process that ensured
he was familiar it was a re-education
program right it was not a re-education
program what do you call it it was a
process to make sure he was familiar
with Colorado law someone might be
excused for calling that a re-education
I strongly disagree just discourse thank
you Mistral
uh no it was a it wasn't a re-education
program it was a
a new instruction seminar yeah yeah
that's the ticket but it totally wasn't
a re-education program and Neil Gorsuch
says yeah okay I think I'm gonna call it
I think I'm going to call it a
re-education program I think I'm going
to stick with that
it reminds me of When Donald Trump who's
arguing about the illegals and during
2016 and someone said you know that term
is very offensive
he says what's offensive about the term
illegals I said what it's just it's
wrong you should say what should I say
you should say future
undocumented uh dreaming any kinds of I
said I think I'm going to stick with
illegal actually and that's what Neil
Gorsuch says which is amazing from Neil
Gorsuch because Neil Gorsuch was the
deciding vote in the Bostock case which
found preposterously
that civil rights law protects
sexual orientation and gender identity
that when you see protections for sex in
the civil rights law that also implies a
protection for gender identity which is
distinct from sex by the very
nature of this gender category right the
the gender ideologues say well you can
have some sex you can be a male as as
your biological sex but you can be a
female as a matter of your gender so
Neil Gorsuch has been far from Rock
ribbed on these issues and even he is
sitting there saying are you kidding me
Colorado
are you kidding me that you're going to
force people to do this and especially
when we're talking about creating a
wedding website because there you're
talking about forcing someone to engage
in speech that they find immoral
an example of this would be I've worked
on political campaigns I've written
political speeches before
now let's say I've got Michael Knowles
speech writing LLC
and I'm a business and I write speeches
for conservatives and then one day a
communist walks in and says Michael I
want you to write a speech for me I'm
running to be the Communist nominee for
president and I say well sorry Mr
communist but I'm a conservative and so
I I'm not going to write a speech
extolling the virtues of communism
and then I get dragged before The
Supreme Court
and they say this man has discriminated
against me he has refused me Service as
a this is a horrible example of bigotry
and then the libs the lib justices say
Michael you're forced to use your speech
use your faculties of reason to
participate in this communist campaign
that's that's what we're talking about
here you are you are forced to use your
speech and your skill and your time in
your labor to violate your conscience at
a very very deep level and so Neil
Gorsuch is calling this out
unfortunately the newest Justice on the
Supreme Court katanji Jackson
did not call it out she was clearly on
the side of Colorado
what I'm asking you is I have a public
business I'm a photographer my belief is
that you know uh I'm doing It's a
Wonderful Life scenes that's what I'm
offering okay I want to do video
depictions If It's a Wonderful Life and
um I knowing that movie very well I want
to be authentic and so only white
children and families can be uh uh
customers for that particular product
everybody else can I'll give to
everybody else I'll sell them anything
they want just not the It's a Wonderful
Life depictions
um I'm expressing something right for
your purposes at that speech what about
uh what's the other step it's speech and
I can say anti-discrimination laws can't
make me sell the It's a Wonderful Life
package to
non-white individuals
I'd like to apologize
previously on this show I have said that
I thought that katanji Jackson is a
smart woman
and I've said this because she has two
degrees from Harvard that should have
been my first warning actually and I've
said this because she was a federal
judge and I've said you know she's very
very confused this woman but I bet she's
intelligent
I I retract that statement
uh hearing
hearing that
babbling nonsense masquerading as an
argument I can no longer defend the
claim that I am confident that katanji
Jackson is an intelligent woman
thought she was but maybe not I guess I
guess my other clue should have been
when she couldn't Define the word woman
during her Senate confirmation what is
this woman saying she's saying well this
case
where a woman doesn't want to
participate in a gay wedding quote
unquote gay wedding I shouldn't even use
the phrase because it's a it's a
contradiction in terms and this is how
the labs control your mind as they get
you they control all the words you use
and they they force you to accept their
premises as a matter of your own speech
but this woman is being forced to
participate in an activity that she
finds immoral and to do so with her own
speech
that is not the same as saying
hey hey gay people you can't buy my
pictures
hey black people you can't buy my
pictures hey I mean this this is the
silly notion
that judge Justice Gorsuch disabused the
Colorado solicitor general up when he
said you're excluding customers based on
some group characteristic they said not
at all you're just refusing to
participate in an activity
now if catanji Jackson had said you know
uh you're a photographer you want to
create real realistic depictions of the
movie It's a Wonderful Life
and you recognize that George Bailey is
a white guy so you're only going to cast
white guys in these pictures to be
Recreations of its Wonderful Life
I guess then you would be discriminating
on People based on their race but one
that's already protected it's called
casting of course you can catch you know
if I if I go in to audition for the next
Black Panther movie and they don't give
me the part I can't sue them and say
this was discrimination based on my race
how dare they not cast me an olive skin
to Sicilian American as the role of
whatever the guy I don't know what the
guy's name is I didn't it's no not my
cup of tea okay but no of course that is
is already protected and in that case of
course by the way the the person you
would be casting is not a customer he's
an employee and you're allowed to
discriminate when it comes to employees
especially if their appearance matters
so that and no one's arguing otherwise
it's just the argument either katanji
Jackson is much much less intelligent
than I thought she was or she they're
not even attempting to make a convincing
argument it could be the latter because
this was at the heart of the gay
marriage so-called debate was the libs
never had that debate
the debate was always over what is
marriage
and the libs never had that debate they
just begged the question they assumed
their own conclusion and they said
marriage is the union of any two people
that I say it is a union of and so now
that the question becomes who has the
right to get married and it seems that
katanji Jackson is doing exactly the
same thing here now speaking of weird
sex stuff
there are protests right now
in 20 cities over not over the
redefinition of marriage
not even over the transgender stuff
which is the
next stage of that part of the sexual
Revolution
over Balenciaga
you remember the Balenciaga campaign
we've talked about it on this show and I
keep bringing it up because I don't want
the story to get memory hold Balenciaga
a very very high-end luxury fashion
house
that has celebrity relationships with
every famous person under the sun
certainly all the big prominent Libs who
go to the elite parties they they pushed
advertising campaigns that sexualized
children
little kids in them frowning looking
unhappy holding s m teddy bears and in
another advertising campaign you had the
text to a Supreme Court decision about
child pornography referencing another
Supreme Court decision about child
pornography and that the decision that
it was referencing in that very
meticulously placed court case the
decision was referencing was one which
held the
alleged constitutionality of simulated
child pornography so the whole thing was
super weird you saw satanic references
references to Baal one of the most
prominent demons ever worshiped in in
one of their advertising inmates so the
whole thing was really sick really weird
getting involved sex stuff and kids and
people are rightly Furious about it
so what is happening well Balenciaga is
apologizing Balenciaga
tried to do damage control right away
and this was
a little awkward for the liberals who
reacted to the conservatives observing
this weird sex stuff by saying this is
nothing this is not a big deal you guys
are tinfoil hat conspiracy theorists
what are you talking about and then
Balenciaga goes wipes their social media
networks Instagram all gone other than a
major apology says that they were going
to seek a a lawsuit against the person
who put the photo shoot together so that
really undercut the libs who were saying
this is nothing Burger it's no big deal
but then Balenciaga otherwise was
largely silent about this until now
[Music]
is a Georgian fashion designer he's
currently the creative director for
Balenciaga
super tight with Kim Kardashian he's
collaborated with Kanye West before
Kanye oddly enough during his sort of
performance art presidential campaign
continues to wear Balenciaga clothing
and I think actually defended this guy
demna gavazalia even amid his seemingly
extremely super duper far-right campaign
he's defending Balenciaga
and all these kind of weird liberal
creative types who are pushing the kids
sex stuff which is very very strange but
regardless that's just a little bit of a
footnote but a strange footnote on the
story a demna says
I want to personally apologize for the
wrong artistic choice of concept for the
gifting campaign with the kids and I
take my responsibility it was
inappropriate to have kids promote
objects that had nothing to do with them
the 41 year old posted okay
just want to push back a little here
they were holding teddy bears
so
the teddy bears happened to be wrapped
up in this weird S M Leather sex stuff
but you can't say that the object they
were holding had nothing to do with them
the object they were holding was a teddy
bear which has a lot to do with little
kids
part of what's so creepy here is not
just that there were kids in the ad
kids were holding a a kid object that
had been sexualized
it's weird that the the kids were in the
ad at all but the just the fact that a
little teddy bear was being so
sexualized that is also weird so that's
already making me think hold on wait
what you're you want to apologize
for the artistic choice of concept but
now yeah it doesn't seem like you're
being totally honest if you're saying an
s m teddy bear has nothing to do with
kids he says as much as I would
sometimes like to provoke a thought
through my work I would never have an
intention to do that with such an awful
subject as child abuse that I condemn
period
now this is another another little weird
thing I just noticed this now in the in
the way the sentence is written
he says I would never do it with such an
awful subject as child abuse that I
condemn he doesn't say I would never do
it with child abuse comma which I
condemn which would say I condemn child
abuse per se it's he says I would never
engage with an awful subject as child
abuse that I condemn the difference
being that because he's not condemning
child abuse is a category there might be
some kind of child abuse that he does
not condemn
it would be like saying I'd hold up a
blue m m and I say these are the M Ms
that I love
I love the blue M M's The Other M M's
the jury is at or I could say these are
the M Ms which I love that would I would
say I love these M M's is demna
gavazalia thinking that deeply about the
syntax here I'm not so sure but it that
is just kind of weird taken in the
context of the whole statement because
he then he goes on he says I need to
learn from this listen and engage with
child protection organizations to know
how I can contribute and help on this
terrible subject I apologize to anyone
offended by the visuals and Balenciaga
has guaranteed that adequate measures
will be taken not only to avoid similar
mistakes in the future but also to take
accountability in protecting child
welfare in every way we can again here
you see kind of a fake apology
I apologize to anyone offended by da da
da
that's that's
the the lamest kinds of apology you can
make
when when you say hey I'm sorry if you
were offended by what I said no that's
not an apology you can't apologize for
the way someone feels you can only
apologize for your own actions
so you can say I apologize that I put
this together
I apologize that I did a thing that is
offensive
we didn't say that apologize to anyone
offended
and I guarantee uh we'll take steps to
protect this in the future and then in
conjunction with this announcement
Balenciaga said that it would drop its
25 million dollar lawsuit against the
marketing agency North six which put
this together
shows you that Balenciaga bore much more
responsibility for the campaign than
they wanted to admit
why are they dropping the lawsuit
they're dropping the lawsuit because it
wasn't just some random marketing
campaign that they hired that went off
on their own and and did this crazy
thing that Balenciaga condemns they're
dropping the lawsuit because they know
that Balenciaga was itself involved in
the campaign
and they're dropping the lawsuit because
valenciaga's creative director is saying
yeah I had an artistic vision and that
wasn't great
that's why they're doing it if
Balenciaga really thought they could get
25 million dollars from this marketing
firm North six they would do it but
Balenciaga is not going to bring the
lawsuit why because they don't want to
go through Discovery and because they
think that they're going to lose the
case
and now Balenciaga says we're gonna
we're gonna donate instead to
organizations focused on protecting
children
oh yeah and also this whole apology
comes two weeks after the fact
two weeks after the fact because the the
controversy hasn't died down because
there are protests in 20 cities I would
not try I do not accept this apology I
do not believe this apology I think this
is Crisis Communications major damage
control it does not seem sincere to me
at all and it seems like there is a lot
more going on behind the scenes at
Balenciaga and I think people should
keep pulling on that thread because
every every single day it seems we learn
something new about what's going on
behind the scenes there and it's really
weird and creepy and freaky and we
should figure it out
speaking of weak apologies
the incoming Democrat minority leader in
the House of Representatives is issuing
a sort of apology
for being himself after two years of
Democrats whining about the evil
election deniers who are a threat to our
democracy the man himself
is a denier of the election of Donald
Trump
the newly elected incoming leader of
house Democrats
is a past election denier
who basically said the 2016 election was
quote
illegitimate
and suggested that we had a quote fake
president suggesting equivalence there
were Donald Trump what's your response
well you know it's unfortunate that
Republicans have chosen to focus on me
house Democrats are going to focus on
solving problems for the American people
but you do did say that history will
never accept Donald Trump as a
legitimate president and the Republicans
are making quite a big issue out of that
what is your response well here's the
Republican Playbook facts don't matter
hypocrisy is not a constraint to their
behavior and in many cases they believe
that shamelessness is a superpower my
view of the situation has been pretty
clear I supported the certification of
Donald Trump's election I attended his
inauguration even though there were many
constituents and others across the
country pushing me and others to do
otherwise well hold on is Trump a
legitimate president or not
because I'm not getting an answer out of
Hakeem Jeffries he won't even answer the
question now he
says he said when Trump was elected this
was an illegitimate election he's an
illegitimate president
then he points out well I voted for the
certification anyway but
an illegitimate president so which isn't
if if Hakeem Jeffries seriously believed
that Donald Trump was illegitimately
elected then he should have voted
against the certification of the vote
right
or if Hakeem Jeffries believed that
Donald Trump was actually elected
president then he should have stopped
being an election denier but he's he's
trying to have it both ways and you can
see this you can tell the man has no
convictions whatsoever because he says
listen I I attended the inauguration
even though
even though what even though my better
judgment told me not to even though I
had a principled stance against it even
though even though no he says even
though some of my constituents didn't
want me to okay so this is a guy
who blows in the wind and who is as the
Democrats so often do projecting his own
vices onto his political opponents when
he says in it preposterously in answer
to the question do you think Trump's an
illegitimate president or not do you
regret dying that election he goes the
Republicans they're Hypocrites they it's
they think they don't have principles
then he just goes on some stupid
campaign platitude you know automation
just because beep beep boop and he just
spits out all these stupid empty talking
points but he himself is the one who is
blowing in the wind here who doesn't
have principles who who I still after
that interview I still don't know
whether he thinks that the 2016 election
was legit or not
and find if he thinks it wasn't legit
produce the evidence I can't I don't see
any the Democrats tried really hard to
do that but he's just trying to have it
both ways and he's not actually
apologizing really really weak stuff now
speaking of rigged elections you know
that the Twitter files just came out
about the ways in which the social media
companies Twitter in particular in this
case worked with the Democrats to rig
the 2020 election according to certain
public polls
show that they may have played the
decisive role by hunt by censoring the
hunter Biden laptop story so green
Jean-Pierre White House spokesman is
asked about this she says
it's old news
we see this as a an interesting or a
coincidence if I may that uh that he
would so haphazardly uh Twitter was so
haphazardly push this distraction that
is a that is a full of old news if you
think about it and at the same time
Twitter is facing very real and very
serious questions about the rising
volume of anger hate and anti-Semitism
on their platform and how they're
letting it happen and you know the
president said last week more leaders
need to speak out and reject this and
it's a very alarming and very dangerous
huh
yeah I get it you don't like Elon Musk
you don't you don't like the
conservatives get to speak on Twitter
but what about the what about the expose
which shows that the Democrats colluded
with Twitter to censor the the content
that was damaging for Joe Biden
what did she say she says oh that's old
news
this is the Clinton Playbook
this is the going back to the early 90s
going back to the 80s
the clintons whenever they were
confronted with a scandal which is
frequent for the clintons even by
Democrat standards what would they do
they would deny deny deny deny deny deny
deny deny deny deny deny deny deny
oh it's old news
they would deny it for years and then
when it was undeniable they would say oh
it's old news no it's not yeah it's old
news that you've been lying about for
years you've never actually had to
confront any of this so you don't you
don't get to just slip away that's what
they're trying to do and this is the
strongest evidence that what was exposed
in the Twitter files is not a nothing
Burger
the fact that Democrats did their best
for two years to cover it up
and now they're trying to say well it's
old if it was old news if it's no big
deal then why didn't you deal with it at
the time because it is a big deal and
there's much more to come by the way I I
think that that Twitter Twitter gate
Twitter files thread that the journalist
meant tahibi posted the other day I
think that was not the full story I
think that was the tip of the iceberg
are you the conservative Uncle who
showed up to Thanksgiving well now
you're back for Christmas right and you
are bringing the new range of Jeremy's
Razor's hair body and skin care products
I've actually got them right here
and not only do I have them I I have
them here on my desk and I have them in
my shower and let me tell you something
these products are amazing so obviously
they got the razors and they got the new
five blade razor that's awesome fabulous
fabulous razor but they've got the
shampoo they've got the body wash
they've got the body soap they've got
this nice brush thing they've got
they've got all these products and I'll
tell you I just I just reusing the
shampoo so I was a little skeptical I
would have used it anyway even when we
just made a pure poison chemicals
because I love Jeremy's razors I think
it is emission I think it was an actual
crucial to the conservative mission that
we support Jeremy's razors over the woke
companies that want to trans all our
kids but it turns out
the ingredients in Jeremy's razors are
extremely high-end natural crunchy
ingredients that sweet little Elisa
makes me use all over our house so none
of this stuff is that really awful
synthetic dangerous got a poisonous
stuff that you see really really
wonderful natural ingredients uh very
high-end stuff uh our executive who is
running Jeremy's razors day to day right
now happens to be much like sweet little
Elisa an absolute obsessive about all of
the natural good ingredients so the libs
and the what corporations don't poison
us and turn the freaking frogs gay and
all that sort of stuff so anyway you got
to go check it out uh Jeremy's razors
right now head on over to Jeremy's
razors.com you get 30 off razor gift
bundles tea tree and peppermint shampoo
and conditioner bamboo charcoal facial
cleanser but the Precision 5 Blade with
a flip black trimmer they've got
everything okay 30 off gift bundles
right now if you order before December
15th go to dailywire.com
scanner w l e s daily wire.com slash
nulls
the the mat taibi thread was the tip of
the iceberg as far as I'm concerned
because
we already know
that the other social media networks
have been pressured by democrats to
censor their content to give Democrats
an advantage and to harm the Republicans
one of the criticisms of the Twitter
files thread is the libs are saying well
there's no evidence that the government
forced Twitter to do any of this stuff
is another the government it was maybe
the DNC or the Dem wasn't a government
well
now we've got
some evidence that the the FBI actually
was involved we know that Mark
Zuckerberg said on Joe Rogan's show that
the FBI called up Facebook and told them
that there was this Hunter Biden laptop
store and they should be very very
skeptical of it and it was a big warning
about allowing this story to spread it
was basically the the FBI saying shut
down this story because it's going to
hurt the the Democrats well it turns out
on another story damaging to Democrats
the FBI got involved as well do you
remember the story of Tara Reid Tara
Reid is the former Hill staffer who
accused Joe Biden of sexually assaulting
her some decades ago
apparently
Twitter now reveals the FBI asked
Twitter for This Woman's personal
information
Daily Caller has this report
The subpoena was obtained by Daily
Caller and it shows the doj asking
Twitter to testify in front of a grand
jury to provide quote all subscriber
information for Reed's accounts
so that includes obviously
name
[Music]
logins where she was logging in from
time on the site credit cards if she was
subscribed say to Twitter blue or
something or any of the other
subscriptions where you would spend
money on Twitter to promote ads or
things like that
very very personal information why Tara
Reid says she has no reason why she has
no idea why other than
because she was going after Joe Biden we
know this is happening
we know that the FBI has been weaponized
by the Democrats against the Republicans
that's what the Russia hoax was about
that's what happened when the FBI
illegitimately spied on Donald Trump's
campaign and then undermined his
presidency we know this is happening and
so I suspect Elon Musk is a pretty
sophisticated player you don't think I'm
the world's richest man by accident okay
and so Elon Musk says the big Twitter
files release and it shows that the
conservatives are not crazy it shows
evidence of corruption but it's not some
big huge bombshell with stories we
didn't know about and then the libs
laugh about it they mock it do we really
think that's all that there is here I
don't believe that for one second
okay it's corruption
it's corruption from the Biden
Administration so the Biden
Administration it's not they're not
going to fix our economy they're not
going to secure our borders they're not
going to prevent the breakout of World
War III they're not going to do anything
that the American people really want but
they are taking one really bold stand
Joe Biden
he just came out he took a courageous
stand against Hitler
yeah that's right against Hitler and the
Holocaust wow
wow amazing what courage
oh those are the issues that are the the
war that occurred 70 years ago that
statistically 100 of people with maybe a
few exceptions agree on uh that's what
he's going to take the stand up
he says I just want to make a few things
clear
the Holocaust happened Hitler was a
demonic figure and instead of giving it
a platform our political leaders should
be calling out and rejecting
anti-Semitism wherever it hides silence
is complicity this reminds me of a norm
McDonald's bit Norm would do a lot of
Hitler jokes he did one famously on
David Letterman's last episode
of uh of of his Network show and the
jokes were always that of course
everybody agrees on Hitler you know but
he would say that it's some sort of
controversial stance he say you know the
more I read about this Hitler fella the
more I don't like him
that Hitler you know I don't know if
you're a history buff I was reading
about this guy Hitler seems like a real
jerk
okay but the reason I bring it up is not
because this is newsworthy at all this
is about the most boring statement you
could possibly make but it's interesting
in one regard
which is that Joe Biden just proved my
point about Hitler when I was discussing
the Kanye West interview heard around
the world on the Alex Jones Show
some people were confused because the
headline was Kanye West says I love
Hitler but then Kanye West also said I
love Mao I love Stalin I love all of
these other uh terrible dictators who
had a much higher body count than Adolf
Hitler but why is it that
that doesn't
resonate as much for people that doesn't
offend people as much if someone comes
out and says I love Mao
no one really cares you hear this on
college campuses all the time
kids will wear t-shirts with Che
guevara's face on it
or any other communist killer
but if anyone ever said anything like I
like Hitler or something like that you
know they would be taken away in a
straitjacket they would be severe
disciplinary measures so why is that and
what I said was the reason that there is
a double standard when it comes to
Hitler and Stalin or Hitler and Mao is
because Hitler in the popular
Consciousness is actually synonymous
with the Devil
and actually in a way he is more evil
than the devil because a lot of people
don't believe in the devil but everybody
everybody believes in Hitler and Hitler
was incarnate the devil is pure Spirit
but Hitler was a person with flesh and
blood who moved around in time and space
and so
he he has taken on in our language and
in our perception this
this synonymous character with the very
Devil Himself which is not true of
Stalin and not true of now no matter you
can say whatever you could say that Mao
and Stalin were worse you could say that
they killed more people you but that
doesn't matter that's not how we
understand these figures in our
Collective Consciousness and Joe Biden
just proves that he says Hitler is
demonic but he wouldn't say that about
any other evil leader in the world and
so that is why and and that is why
Kanye's statement I said was in keeping
with the three troubles that he's had in
his public life
which is Kanye West
obviously has mental disorder
he has said and done things that are
disordered going back decades now
and Kanye West is so deeply contrarian
that he always has to violate the next
biggest taboo
you see this you actually see this going
back to Kanye West's music
when Kanye West entered the scene in
hip-hop all the hip-hop was this
gangster rap really violent tough stuff
and then Kanye West comes in with those
songs 18 years 18 years good morning
right it's all this kind of poppy or
lighter stuff that was that was a
violation of the the culture of hip-hop
at the time it was very contrarian then
he goes up to Taylor Swift who's
accepting an award Taylor Swift the most
popular woman in the world practically
he goes up and takes her trophy away and
says I'm going to give it to Beyonce
instead huge violation of a taboo then
you certainly you saw it when Kanye West
said slavery was a choice then you saw
it even more so when you put on the Maga
hat which at that time was akin to
saying I support the devil or I support
Hitler or something and then now you see
it with Kanye West going out and saying
I really like Hitler
or I love Hitler whatever he said
the the trouble for Kanye West now oh
and then then obviously the third
trouble he's got right now is this very
public lapse of this marriage and which
is the sort of thing that makes anybody
go crazy and especially if you've got
other problems it just is very very
challenging which is why I said reaction
to Kanye I'm not going to just castigate
him and you know scold him and preen and
virtue signal I'm going to just say pray
for Kanye he's obviously having a tough
time uh but right now as Joe Biden is
showing
what's the next thing for Kanye he has
violated the ultimate taboo there is no
further taboo to violate in our popular
culture so what does one do what does
one do when the shock value run there is
nothing left to do that is more shocking
in our popular culture now speaking of
Hitler I do have
what a segue I have to get to the story
about time man of the year
because there's a lot of talk about who
will be the time man of the year
the potential candidates right now that
were just floated on The Today Show Ron
DeSantis Liz Cheney Elon Musk
uh Janet Yellen treasury secretary Xi
Jinping
Vladimir zielinski in Ukraine the
Supreme Court
Mackenzie Scott for some reason that's
Jeff bezos's wife or ex-wife the Iran
protesters
and gun safety advocates who is it going
to be Liz Cheney
okay give me give me a break first of
all has Liz Cheney gonna be the man of
the year that doesn't make any sense
although they've renamed it now it's the
person of the year well
since I was the 2006 Time person of the
year I would like to place my debts
Rhonda Sanders should have a good shot
at it he's had a better year than
anybody in American politics Liz Cheney
of course not Elon Musk probably
deserves it he has been a figure of
chaos and very important change to
America's political order he comes in
and he says we will not we are going to
reinstate Donald Trump's account the one
of the biggest shifts in our political
order was this idea that oligarchs in
Silicon Valley were able to silence the
duly elected sitting president of the
United States it's a major shift to the
way American politics Works Elon Musk
comes in and corrects that I think he's
got a really good claim to it
Yellen no Xi Jinping I don't think so uh
the U.S Supreme Court may be because of
Roe v Wade Mackenzie Scott of course not
Iran protesters no gun safety Advocates
what is that who's not a gun safety
Advocate who's a gun
danger Advocate I don't nobody so no the
one they're probably going to give it to
though
silenski right they're probably going to
give it to Vladimir zielinski he's lost
some public favor in in recent weeks
because he keeps trying to instigate the
West into starting World War III and he
also fired those missiles into Poland
and blamed Russia then it turned out it
was Ukraine so it didn't work but if I
had to bet
I would bet
I guess I would bet
zielinski now we've got to talk about
all sorts of manly things on the member
block notably
we've got to talk about
sperm
we have to talk about I didn't really
want to talk about sperm but my friend
Cabot Phillips
you know Cabot Phillips here from the
daily wire he said Michael I want to
come on the show and talk about sperm
now there's not enough of it these days
the men are atrophying
apparently a major problem in the
country so we will discuss sperm coming
up the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]